number three in Portugal the volvo ocean
race began its eighth leg babe ligature
greeley chotto shot it's a good morning
departed Lisbon was there gonna sail 650
miles to the next checkpoint which is
Laurie on France which is the Brittany
party prance at the top and all women's
crew named team SCA is currently in the
lead the race sounds more than 39,000
nautical miles 11 countries it's going
to end in swim is this just rich guys
playing what is the source of course
there's a rich guys playing well I know
it's it's also there's a there's an
all-chinese team now it's a little bit
of rich guy ambition a little bit of
national pride perform in a world of
various technological advancement no and
in fact all the technological
advancement I think right now has moved
to the Americas couple let's be honest I
love this stuff but sailing is
desperately trying to make itself more
attractive to people it's doing what you
saw there was also they tried to do an
in Harbor race in Lisbon so that more
people would pay attention before they
set off out under the great it's a hard
it's hard to watch I love sailing it is
hard to watch hmm ok well there it is
what next ok number two last week in
London the mysterious shipping crate
appeared at the waterloo station then
yesterday morning for velociraptors
emerged from the container they were not
going commuters were able to get up
close and take pictures it's old hype up
the movie Jurassic Park which premieres
this Friday in the US and we took the
bait we also have to say Bonnie going
you have you had the comment of the
morning mr. a meeting which was so this
is a marketing ploy and we've fallen
into it well they look like the guys at
Blackrock looking for five more basis
points Jeff Rosenberg is surveillance
movie critic today are you gonna go see
Jurassic Park the whatever it is so cool
sure yeah yeah yeah you lie just like I
mean doing do we think it's an accident
that the promo was in Waterloo station
for this new Jurassic Park movie I'm not
getting Shh continue the link you can
explain later number one in New York
this one is dear oh I just said this on
his dear it's the world's smallest
dearest species and it was born at the
queens zoo that's called voodoo or a poo
Doo that's not his name that's the
species it's native to South America the
phone is yet to be named but when
they're born food is our only six inches
high and way less than a pallet excuse
me
little detail stop some daughter of a
hedge fund manager is gonna be walking
this thing got Madison Avenue in six
weeks Oh gonna be a poopy let me up who
do right now please no we want we want a
poodle and be sure the kennel will take
it on the weekends thank you